Specify your goal.
If you do that,
you do that in some sense as a unique
individual.
You want to.
You want to specify goals that make you
say,
Oh,
if that could happen as a consequence of
my efforts,
it would clearly be worthwhile because
the question always is,
why do something?
Because doing nothing is easy.
You just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy.
The question is why would you ever do
anything and the answer that has to be
because you've determined by some means
that it's worthwhile and then the next
question might be,
well,
where should you look for worthwhile
things and one would be,
well,
you could consult your own temperament
and the other would be while you kinda
look at how.
Look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan.
Look,
look what so you do a structural
analysis of the sub components of human
existence and already did that.
You need a family.
You need friends like you don't need to
have all of these things,
but you better have most of them.
Family,
friends,
career,
educational goals,
plans for time outside of work,
attention to your mental and physical
health,
etc.
You know those are,
that's what life is about.
And if You don't have any of those
things,
well then all you've got left is misery
and suffering,
so that's a bad,
that's a bad deal for you.
So,
so once you,
once you set up that,
that goal structure,
let's say,
and that's really in many in many ways,
that's what you should be doing at
universities is,
that's exactly what you should
you're doing is trying to figure out who
it is that you're trying to be,
right?
And you aim at that and then use
everything you learn as a means of
building that person that you want to
be.
And,
and I really mean want to be.
I don't mean should be even those
things,
those things are going to overlap and
it's important to distinguish between
those because that's partly,
and this is back down to the micro
routine analysis.
So ashley is saying,
well,
you're going to try to make yourself
more industrious.
Okay?
Number one,
specify your damn goals because how are
you going to hit something if you don't
know what it is that isn't going to
happen,
and often people won't specify their
goals too because they don't like to
specify conditions for failure.
So if you keep yourself all vague and
foggy,
which is real easy because that's just a
matter of not doing as well.
Then you don't know when you fail and
people might say,
well,
I really don't want to know when I fail
because that's painful,
so I'll,
I'll keep myself blind about when I
fail.
ThAt's fine,
except you'll fail all the time.
Then you just won't know it until you
failed so badly that you're done.
And that can easily happen by the time
you're 40.
So.
So I would recommend that you don't let
that happen.
So that's willful blindness,
right?
You could have known,
but you chose not to.
Okay?
So once you get your goal structure set
up,
you think,
okay,
if I could have this life looks like
that might be worth living,
despite the fact that it's going to be
anxiety provoking and threatening and
there's gonna be some suffering and loss
involved in all of that.
Obviously the goal is to to have a
vision for your life such that all
things considered that justifies your
effort.
Okay.
So then what do you do?
Well then then you turn down to the
micro routines,
just like,
okay,
well this is what I'm aiming for.
How does that instantiates itself day to
day,
week to week,
month to month.
And that's where something like a
schedule can be unbelievably useful.
Google calendar.
It's like naked damn schedule and stick
to it.
Okay.
So what's the rule with the schedule?
It's not a bloody prison.
That's the first thing that peter,
I
will do wrong.
He said,
well I don't like to follow a schedule
once,
like,
well what kind of schedule are you
setting up?
Well I,
I have to do this,
then I have to do this,
you know?
And then I just go play video games
because he wants to do all these things
that I have to do.
It's like wrong.
Set the damn schedule up so that you
have the day you want.
That's the trick.
It's like,
okay,
I've got tomorrow.
If I was going to set it up so it was
the best possible day I could have
practically speaking,
what would it look like?
Well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense,
one of the things that you're gonna
insist upon is that at the end of the
day,
you're not in worse shape than you were
then at the beginning of the day,
right?
Because that's a stupid day.
If you have a bunch of those in a row,
you just dig,
dig yourself a hole,
and then you bury yourself in.
It's like,
sorry,
that's just not a good strategy.
It's a bad strategy.
So maybe 20 percent of your day has to
be responsibility and obligation,
or maybe it's more than that,
depending on how far behind you are.
But even that you can,
you can ask yourself,
okay,
well I've got these responsibilities,
I have to schedule the damn things in.
What's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward?
And you can ask yourself that just like
you'd negotiate with someone who is
working for you.
It's like,
okay,
you gotta work tomorrow.
Okay,
so I want you to work tomorrow.
And you might say,
okay,
well what are you going to do for me
that makes it likely that I'll work for
you while you could ask yourself that,
you know,
maybe you do an hour of,
of responsibility and then you play a
video game for 15 minutes.
I don't know,
whatever turns your crank man.
but you know,
you have to negotiate with yourself and
not tyrannized yourself like you're
negotiating with someone that you care
for that you would like to be productive
and have a good life.
And,
and that's how you make the schedule.
It's like.
And then you look at the day and you
think,
well,
if I had that day,
that'd be good.
Great.
You know,
and you,
you're useless and horrible.
So you'll probably only hit it with
about 70 percent accuracy,
but that beats the hell out of zero,
right?
And if you hit it even with 50 percent
accuracy,
another rule is well,
aim for 51 percent the next week or 50
and a half percent for god's sake or
because you're going to hit that
position where things start to loop back
positively and spiral you upward and so,
so that's one way that you can work on
your conscientiousness is a plan a life
you'd like to have,
and you do that partly by referring to
social norms.
That'S more or less rescuing your father
from the belly of the whale,
but the other way you do that is by
having a little with yourself
about as if you don't really know who
you are because you know what you're
like.
You won't do what you're told.
You won't do what you tell yourself to
do.
You must have noticed that.
It's like you're a bad employee and a
worse boss and both of those work for
you.
You don't know what you want to do and
then when you tell yourself what to do,
you don't do it anyways.
You should fire yourself and find
someone else to beat.
But,
but you know,
my point is,
is that you have to understand that
you're not your own servant,
so to speak.
You're someone that you have to
negotiate with and that's.
And you're someone that you want to
present the opportunity of having a good
life too.
And that's hard for people because they
don't like themselves very much.
so you know,
they're always like cracking the whip
and then procrastinating and cracking
the whip and then procrastinating and
it's like so boring and such a pathetic
way of spending your time.
And you know what that's like because he
probably wasted like six hours a day and
I think
we did an economic calculation about
that awhile back.
Right?
Your time is probably worth 50 bucks an
hour,
something like that.
I mean,
you're not getting paid that now,
but you're young.
and so this is investment time and what
you do now is going to multiply its
effects in the future.
So,
so let's say it's 50 bucks an hour,
which is perfectly reasonable.
So if you waste six hours a day and you
are,
then you're wasting about $2,000
a week or about $100,000
a year.
So like go ahead.
But that's what it's costing you every
hour and you need to know what your damn
time is worth.
So let's say it's not 50 bucks,
it's 30,
whatever.
Maybe it's a hundred.
It's somewhere in that range.
One of the things that you should be
asking yourself is when you spend an
hour was that,
well,
what have I paid someone 50 bucks to
have had that hour?
And if that answer is no,
it's like,
well maybe you should do something else
with your time.
and it depends on whether or not you
think that your time is worthwhile.
But the funny thing about not assuming
that is if you assume your time isn't
worthwhile,
what happens is you don't just sit
around sort of randomly in a state of
responsibility lists bliss.
What you do is you suffer existentially.